So let's go ahead and take a look at my
test code for the Q class. So it doesn't actually take
a whole lot to get full coverage on the Q
class, and that's, this is a good point, we haven't tested
the Q a huge amount here. It shows a little
bit of the problems with S, especially just normal statement coverage,
so let's go ahead and get started. So we start
off with just a Q of size 2, we assert that
it does actually get made and then we call check
rep, we're going to be calling check rep after every single test
that we do, just as a further test. And really, any
of the test that we do that call the internals of
the q class should probably be in check wrap, because
we don't necessarily want our test code to have to worry
about the internals of it, we want the internal testing to
be taken care of by the class itself. Preferably all though
you dont always get that. But after that we check
the que it starts off as empty. Which it should
be. And that the que is not full. Which it
also should not be. And then we try the que from
the empty que. And this should return none according to
specification. Then we're going to que ten in to the
que. And we should get a true. Result back and
enqueue returns true if you successfully enqueue something, false, if it
doesn't correctly enqueue for some reason or another. Then, we enqueue
20 and again, it should be true. Now, we check that
it's empty again. It should not be empty and we check
that it's full. Since it's a queue of size two, the
full method should return true. And that's what we asset here.
Now, we further try to enqueue thirty, but since the queue
should already be full, this should return false. And we go
ahead and assert that. Now we try to dequeue from that, and
we should get 10 out since this is a q. It's a
first in, first out data structure. Then we try to dequeue again,
and We should get 20 out. And, again, after each of these,
we call tech rep. If I go ahead and submit this, we
see that I got it right. Okay. Os, that's one way you
could have done it. There are a number of different possibilities here.
And like I said, it doesn't really take a huge amount of
code to get full coverage of the queue class. If fact, what I
did here is probably a bit much. But again. It doesn't necessarily tell us
a whole lot about whether the Q class is, in fact, correct in any
meaningful way. So, great. I hope you got it right and had fun with
it. I hope it also wasn't too challenging. But I hope it made you think.